what we're going to think about in this
video is elasticity of demand to
t
elasticity of
demand
and what this is is a measure of how
does the quantity demanded change given
a change in price or how does a change
in price impact the quantity demanded so
change in price
change
change in price change in price
change in price
impact
impact quantity i want to be careful
here quantity demanded when you talk
about demand you're talking about the
whole curve quantity demanded is a
specific quantity
quantity demanded
quantity demanded
and the way that we as economists i'm
not really an economist but since we're
doing economics we can pretend to be
economists the way that economists
measure this is they measure it as a
percent change
percent change in percent change
in quantity
over a percent over the percent change
change
in price and the reason why they do this
as opposed to just say change in
quantity over change in price is because
if you did change in quantity over
change in price you would have a number
that's specific to the units you're
using so it would depend on whether
you're doing quantity in terms of per
hour per week or per year and so you
would have different numbers based on
the time frame or the units that you
might use but when you use a percentage
when you use a percentage it is a
unitless number because a percentage
you're taking a change in some quantity
divided by
that quantity so the units themselves
actually cancel out and the reason why
it's called elasticity this might make
some sense to you or the reason why i
like to think it's called elasticity is
i imagine something that's elastic like
a elastic band or a rubber band
and in a rubber band if you pull it
depending if something so let's say this
one is let's say this one is inelastic
inelastic
inelastic
so if you pull you're not going to able
to pull it much it's going to be fairly
stiff it's not going to stretch a lot
while if something is elastic if
something is elastic for a given amount
of force so this is for a given amount
of force you're not able to pull it much
and if something is elastic maybe for
the same amount of force you're going to
able to you're going to be able to pull
it a lot
so this right over here is elastic and
so the analogy
maybe might make a little bit sense
relative to apply price and demand
something is elastic
so let me write this down elastic
elastic so let me write very elastic
very elastic if a given change in price
given
price change
you have and and especially we'll talk
about percentages a little bit but the
given change in price you have a large
change in demand so large percentage
change and let me just speak in terms of
percentage given a percentage change
change in p you end up having a large
percentage change
in q that would be very elastic so you
can imagine the p is like the force and
the q the quantity demanded
is how is is how far the the thing can
get stretched apart and that's why we
would call this very elastic just like a
very elastic rubber band and if
something is very inelastic
very inelastic
if given a percent change in p given a
percent change in p you have a small
small percent change
in q
so if just like a rubber band for a
given amount of force if you if you're
not able to pull it much at all then
it's inelastic if you're able to pull it
a lot it's elastic same thing with price
and quantity if you for a given change
in price if it change if the quantity
demanded if the percent quantity
demanded changes a lot very elastic if
it doesn't change a lot very inelastic
now with that out of the way let's
actually calculate the elasticity for
multiple points along this demand curve
right over here and i think that'll give
us a a better grounding especially
because there are a little slightly
slightly
i would call them unusual ways of
calculating the percent change in
quantity in the percent change of price
just so that we get the same number when
we have a positive change in price and
the same as we get the negative change
in price or a negative and a positive or
a drop in price and an increase in price
so let me give myself some real estate
over here because i want to do some
actual mathematics
and actually all of this we will be
reviewing and what i'm about to do and
it'll give me some real estate to work
with so let me clear all of that and let
me clear that right over here and what
i'm going to do is i'm going to
calculate the elasticity of demand at
several points along this demand curve
right over here and so the first one i
will do it at point a to point b so let
me let me make another column right over
here elasticity of demand and actually
we're gonna have one column that's
elasticity of demand so it's a big e
with a little subscript d and the other
one i'll just take its absolute value
because depending on
sometimes people like to just think the
think of the number which will tend to
be a negative number and sometimes
people like to look at the absolute
value of it so we'll look at both and
see what it actually means
so let's say our price drops from point
a to point b so from point a to point b
from point a to point b we have a one
dollar a negative one dollar change in
price and we have a positive so this is
a negative one dollar change in price
and we have a positive two dollar uh
sorry a positive two burger per hour
change in quantity demanded so what is
the elasticity of demand there so let's
write it over here i'll do it in i'll do
it in a's color so the elasticity
of demand remember it's the percent
change in quantity so percent change in
quality rewrite it as percent
change
in quantity
over percent change
in
in
price and so we have what's our percent
change in quantity so it's going to be
the change in quantity over some base
quantity so our change in quantity is 2
so it's going to be equal to 2
over now in traditional terms and this
is what i i want to kind of clarify is a
little bit unusual in how we do it but
we do it so that we get the same
elasticity demand of demand whether we
go from a to b or b to a or essentially
we get the same elasticity of demand
along this whole part of the curve
instead of just dividing the change in
quantity dividing divided by our
starting point what i want to do is i'm
going to divide the change in quantity
divided by the average of our starting
and our ending points so that's going to
be 2 over and i'll actually do the math
explicitly actually let's just think
about what's the average between 2 and 4
well the average is just going to be 3.
that's the average of 2 and 4. i could
write let me write it down just so it's
clear this right over here that right
over here is two plus four
over two that's how you get three that's
how you calculate the average
all right so that is
so that is our proportionate change and
then you want to multiply by a hundred
times 100 to actually get a percentage
and then what is our change in price
well we're going to do the same thing
the act the or the percent change in
price our change in price is negative
one it is negative one
over and once again we don't just do
negative one divided by nine we do it
over the average of eight and nine and
the average of eight and nine is eight
point five
eight point five and then multiply by
100 to get your percentage now these
hundreds obviously cancel out these
hundreds cancel out and so we are going
to be left with when you divide by a
fraction it's the same thing as
multiplying by its inverse so we're
going to get two-thirds
two-thirds times negative
8.5 over one or times negative 8.5 times
negative 8.5
get out our calculator and it is so 2
well i'll multiply 2 times
negative 8.5
and then divided by 3
which gives us negative
5.6667 it's really negative five and two
thirds so i'll just write it negative
i'll round it it's negative 5.67
so this is approximately
approximately equal to negative 5.67
so right over here it's negative 5.67
and this absolute value is obviously
just 5.67
and i'll i'll leave it to you to verify
for yourself that you'll get the same
elasticity of demand using this
technique when you use the average as
your base and the percentage going from
nine to eight is going for
going from nine to eight in price as
going from eight to nine in price which
is different than if you use the nine as
the base or the eight as a base so this
right here is the elasticity of demand
not just at point a you can kind of view
it as the average elasticity of demand
over this little part of the curve which
is really a line in this example over
this part of the of the arc so we'll
write
that part right over here i'll write the
absolute value the absolute value of our
elasticity of demand is 5.67
now let's do the other two the other two
sections right over here so let's think
about what happens let's think about
what happens when we go from c to d
so let's c to d so our elasticity of
demand there so from c to d
we have a change in quantity once again
of plus two and our change in price once
again is negative one but we'll see even
though that the change in quantity over
the change in quantity is the same and
the change in price is the same we're
going to have a different elasticity of
demand because we're start we have
different starting points our starting
points for and our ending points for
price or lower and our starting and
ending points for quantity or higher so
it'll actually change the percentage
so let's see what we get so our percent
change in quantity
we have a change in quantity of
2 and then our average quantity is 9
plus 11 which is 20 divided by 2 is 10.
10
all of that over change percent change
in price so we have negative 1
negative 1. let me scroll down a little
bit
negative 1 divided by the change in
negative 1 divided by the average price
so negative 1 is the change in price and
we want to divide that by the average
price well 550 plus 450 is 10 divided by
2 is 5. so the average the average price
is 5. and we could multiply the
numerator by 100 and the denominator by
100 but that won't that won't change
anything because we could just divide
both by a hundred and so this is equal
to 2 over 10
times dividing by a fraction same thing
as multiplying by its inverse times
negative 5 over 1. and this is just
because 2 over 10 is the same thing as 1
5 1 5 times negative 5 over 1 it is
negative one
so this right over here so our
elasticity of demand right over here is
negative one or its absolute value is
one so the absolute value of the
elasticity of demand right over here is
equal to
one and let's just do one more section
and maybe in the next video we can think
a little bit about what it's telling us
so let's do this last section over here
just for some practice
and i encourage you to pause it and try
it yourself
and so we're going to think about this
section right over here so once again
our change in quantity is plus 2 and our
change in price is negative 1 and our
elasticity of demand change in quantity
2 over average quantity which is 17.
change in price is negative one over
average price one plus two divided by
two is a dollar fifty or a dollar fifty
is right in between these two
divided by a dollar fifty we don't have
to multiply
the numerator and the denominator by 100
because those just cancel out so we get
2 over 17
times negative well we could just write
this as negative dollar fifty
over one and this is equal to getting
our getting our calculator back out
so this is equal to
i'll just write well it's really just
going to be negative 3 over 17 right 2
times negative 50 150 is negative 3 over
17 so negative 3 divided by
17. is equal to negative
0.1 i'll just say negative 0.18
so here it is
negative
0.18 and its absolute value is
0.18 so the elasticity of demand over
here
is 0.18
and i'll leave you there and in the next
video we'll we'll think about these
results a little bit